ALISON GOPNIK: If you look at our history, I think what
will happen is that will change in all
sorts of serious, important ways, and we
won't notice it. Because what always
happens is that the day before you're
born is always Eden and the things that
happen to you in your own lifespan are
always technology and the day after your
children are born is always 'Mad Max,'
right? So we always are in this situation
where we think that the things that
happen to us are technological
innovations, and they're probably going
to end up being Mad Max. But then, of
course, if we think about the things like
the fact that in this room there are
right angles everywhere, it's not like
we're really sitting there saying, "My God,
the right angles! The right angles are
taking over everywhere we look!" Even though the
fact of right angles has made enormous
changes in our lives. Or the fact that
there's print everywhere doesn't strike
us as being something that's this weird
technology, that we're constantly getting
distracted because we have to figure out
what that 'R' is, right? That's just, that's
just part of our lives. And I suspect
what will happen is we'll change in
really deep and profound ways, and we
won't notice it, because it'll be
happening over and across generations.
KEVIN KELLY: That's fantastic, thank you.